you be required congratulations on the
engagement now we know that UN Ben will
live happily ever after and you will be
an amazing Queen we're so glad you
insisted on being the queen of both
auradon and the Isle of the last I've
learned that you can't live in fear
thanks for getting rid of the barrier
forever it really is the best decision
but we have so many questions about what
happens next
welcome to descendants three was an epic
finale to the story of the BK's but
haven't you wondered what would happen
next
keep watching to find out to send in
three finally aired and it was epic we
got to meet Mouse dad Hades now and then
decided to open the barrier forever it's
time for forgiveness it's time for a new
beginning human her gang car now friends
with the core for old love stories
continued and new love stories blossomed
the movies may be over but we can still
imagine what would happen if there were
ever a fourth descendants do you think
they miss us we have a lot of unanswered
questions and we got really attached to
the new characters the new vks
descendants four would probably follow
the new vks the original group of
auradon students are just about done
with school after all they weren't
living in the dorms anymore
so we would get to see a lot more of
Celia dizzy and the twins dizzy and
Celia would become BFFs lectin they
would take on the role of helping the
rest of the kids from the Isle adjust
dizzy would be really popular at school
because of her mad beautician skills
Celia would probably get into some
trouble for various money-making schemes
the cards never lie squeaky and squirmy
are going to do really well now that
they can see their dad regularly they'll
become more confident and outgoing as
they get older auradon prep is going to
get a lot bigger there are a lot of kids
on the Isle who want to study there it's
going to take some getting used to but
we know that fairy godmother can handle
it
wedding bells the royal wedding will be
the biggest event auradon has ever seen
then proposed to mal at the beginning of
descendants 3 we're so glad she accepted
yes
edie is going to design the most
gorgeous wedding dress ever for her
bestie dizzy will do her hair and makeup
mouths bridesmaids will be Eevee uma and
Jane fence groomsmen will be Jay Carlos
and Doug now that Mao is back to having
a relationship with her dad Hades will
be able to walk her down the aisle fairy
godmother will perform the wedding of
course it will be beautiful but because
mal is still a v-k it won't be a boring
stuffy wedding it will be tons of fun
with lots of music and dancing love is
in the air auradon is just full of
awesome love stories Evie and Doug
finally said the l word they realize
that they are in true love since she was
able to break the sleeping spell with a
kiss Evie is going to be really busy
with her fashion business
of course we've only done 5,000 sketches
that reward interest but she'll find
plenty of time for Doug Doug will
definitely propose to her at some point
they just have to be together Carlos and
Jane are basically the cutest couple
ever they both have big plans Carlos
wants to go to college to be a vet and
Jane is so smart she'll definitely be
studying something cool these two will
continue to date through school and what
about the new love story fairy hook is a
shameless flirt but he really just wants
someone to love at the end of descendant
3 he and Audrey have a moment we're glad
that audrey has finally moved on from
Ben and Chad was never a good option she
needed someone just as tough as she is
Harry and Audrey will become a couple
and we totally ship it new friendships
Jay and Gil totally hit it off they're
planning on traveling the world for a
year
junkies are icebergs we'll get to see
some of their adventures but they'll
come back for mal and Ben's wedding of
course
boom and mal will continue to be really
great friends they'll still fight
sometimes because they're getting used
to each other
Huma will work hard to help all of the
kids from the aisle succeed in auradon
she'll become one of mal and Ben's
closest royal advisors I always knew
you'd be part of the solution the
villains descendant 3 left us with some
huge questions about the fate of the
villains the barrier is now open forever
and this is a good sign for all the BK's
but this also means that there
original villains now have access to
magic and auradon then and mal are going
to have to do something about that
some of the villains will find
Redemption and become good and Hades is
definitely one of them I'm sure you to
be very happy together
he just wants his job as god of the
underworld back Jabbar's me and dr.
facili a are also going to be okay they
love their kids more than anything so
they won't mess up their chance to be a
part of their lives but some of the
villains are really rotten to the core
Maleficent is going to have to remain
under lockdown Rolla de Vil needs to
stay far away from dogs and animals
alike we're sure that Malin Ben are up
to the challenge of dealing with the
villains we really hope the isle gets
cleaned up now that they can get to
auradon and back they'll be able to have
more money they can have fresh fruits
and vegetables
hopefully the Isle of the Lost will
become a nice place to live do you agree
with all of our theories what else do
you think would happen if there were
descendants for let us know your
theories in the comments thanks for
watching give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
things we'll catch you later
[Music]